when we analyze the problem about
putting two blocks along frictionless
surface and pushing one and asking what
is the maximum force such that block two
does not slip we had three different
systems and now I want to focus a little
bit on what would happen if we just
naively chose our systems as both blocks
together so let's try to look at the
types of issues that come up when we do
that so once again let's draw Freebody
diagrams now we begin we're pushing
block 1 with a force gravitation is the
sum of these two forces because our
system here is block 1 and block - what
about normal forces well the ground is
acting on block 1 and now here's the
significant thing what about all of
those forces between blocks 1 & 2
well the forces between blocks 1 & 2 are
internal forces
and we saw that they were friction
forces F 1 2 and F 2 1
this was the friction force between the
two blocks but on block 2 to the 1 and
the friction force on block 1 due to -
there were normal forces between these 2
bucks
but these are interaction pairs and the
some of them are 0 and so we see that
all their all the internal forces for
form Newton's third law interaction
pairs and the vectors some of them are 0
and that's why I don't need those
internal forces on my Freebody diagram
if I were to draw them I would have
different arrows for instance I would
have that arrow f2 1 and I would have
the arrow f12 and you can see that the
sum of those cancel I would have the
arrow and 2 1 and I would have the arrow
and 1 2 arrows in opposite directions
the interaction pairs sum to 0 because
they are internal forces and again this
enables us now to just draw F equals m1
plus m2 times the acceleration of the
system and so we have our I hat and our
J hat directions let's pick AI hat and J
hat and now we didn't include the
kinetic friction force of the ground in
that system so let's make sure that
that's there and what we have is F minus
F kinetic equals m1 plus m2 times a and
in the vertical direction we have n
ground 1 minus m1 plus m2 G equals 0
that gave us our same result before
notice that F equals F k plus m1 plus m2
G
we know this is Mew K m1 plus m2 G plus
m1 plus m2 G a so we have the
acceleration of the system depends on
the force
UK m1 plus m2 G divided by m1 plus m2
but notice because our static friction
is an internal force in this system it
never shows up in Newton's second law so
we were never able to apply the
condition that F static max was mu
static and what we call the normal force
between the blocks and so we are unable
to figure out what is the maximum force
all we can say is if I push F that's the
acceleration but I cannot determine what
maximum force will cause block two to
slip with respect to block one so when
you pit your system like this it's very
quick to calculate a no problem about
that but I am NOT able to answer any
questions that require some type of
information about the internal forces so
the art to choosing systems and Freebody
diagrams is to think about the types of
questions you're asking if you have a
question that involves something about a
maximum condition on static friction
then you want to make sure that static
friction is an external force to your
system if it's an internal force like in
this case you will not be able to apply
that condition